Speaker 1: one of the most sort of mask off
moments, literally and metaphorically through
the pandemic about the American right wing
has been the viciousness with which the right
has attacked medical professionals in general
around the pandemic, but in particular the
way Dr. Anthony Fauci has been attacked, not
only in terms of physical threat to the point
where he needs full time security, but attacked
in terms of his motives, attacked through
conspiracies and on and on and on.
And one of the main elected officials who
has been attacking Dr. Fauci is Senator Rand
Paul of Kentucky, who many of you will say
that's Dr. Rand Paul, sir.
Don't forget that, sir.
Sure.
Yeah, but he is an ophthalmologist and not
an infectious disease specialist, and he is
again tangling up with Dr. Fauci.
Dr. Fauci seems to have just had enough at
one point telling Rand Paul that if anybody's
lying, it's him, which we will get to.
But first saying that Rand Paul has no idea
what he's talking about.
Let's look at let's really look at this first
exchange here from yesterday's hearing.
And by the way, Rand Paul seems just obsessed
with Fauji.
It's like Groundhog Day.
Every single one of these hearings with these
two
Speaker 2: new potential pandemic pathogens,
potential pandemic pathogens that exist only
in the lab, not in nature.
This research matches these are Dr. Ebright
words.
This research matches, indeed epitomizes the
definition of gain of function, research done
entirely and move on for which there was supposed
to be a federal pause.
Dr. Falchi, knowing that it is a crime to
lie to Congress, do you wish to retract your
statement of May 11?
Speaker 1: So already, I mean, implying that
that Foushee has perjured himself by lying?
Speaker 2: You claim that the NIH never funded
gain of function research and we were on.
I have a microphone.
In to Senator Paul.
I have never lied before the Congress and
I do not retract that statement.
This paper that you were referring to was
judged by qualified staff up and down the
chain as not being gain of function.
What was.
Let me finish an animal virus and you increase
your ability to humans.
Right.
You're saying that's not going to fall?
Yeah, that is correct.
And Senator Paul, you do not know what you
are talking about, quite frankly.
And I want to say that officially, you do
not know what you are talking about.
OK, you get an unprecedented speech from the
NIH tonight,
Speaker 1: and it's not like he's not even
allowed to fully answer.
The question is this.
Rand Paul is just some of the worst of the
worst of the American political establishment.
Speaker 2: And this is your definition that
you guys wrote.
It says that scientific research that increases
the transmissibility about transmissibility
among mammals is a gain of function.
They took animal viruses that only occur in
animals and they increase their transmissibility
to humans.
How you can say that is not to follow.
It is not.
It's a dance.
And you're dancing around this because you're
trying to obscure responsibility for four
million people dying around the world from
a pandemic.
Speaker 1: And that's only because in other
contexts, the pandemic isn't serious.
So when it's convenient for Rand Paul to,
say, masks closure's guidelines, restrictions,
this isn't nearly serious enough.
And now he's saying this is so serious, Dr.
Fauci, that you're lying to us.
Speaker 2: Well, now you're getting into something.
If the point that you were making is that
the the grant that was funded as a sub award
from HECO Health to Wuhan created sars-cov-2.
That's where you are getting.
Speaker 1: OK, so again, it's just endless
with Rand Paul.
We've talked about the gain of function stuff
a number of times already.
At the end of the day, you could say this
could just come down to a sort of semantic
disagreement between entities in terms of
definitions of gain of function.
But the obsession of Rand Paul is what just
cannot be understood here.
Let's look at a little more.
And here's where Foushee says if anybody here
is lying to you, Rand Paul,
Speaker 2: for four million people dying around
the world from a pandemic.
And let's let Dr. I have to.
Well, now you're getting into something.
If the point that you are making is that the
the grant
Speaker 1: and there's a little bit of overlap
here for which I apologize.
Speaker 2: Funded as a sub award from AECO
Health to Human Created sars-cov-2.
That's where you are getting.
Let me finish.
We don't know.
Wait, wait a minute.
I come in the lab at all.
The evidence is pointing that it came from
the lab.
You there will be responsibility for those
who funded the lab, including yourself.
I totally.
Speaker 1: Rand Paul is blaming Dr. Fouchier
for the pandemic.
Speaker 2: This committee won't allow the
witness to.
I totally resent the lie that you are now
propagating, Senator, because if you look
at the viruses that were used in the experiments
that were given in the annual reports that
were published in the literature, it is molecularly
impossible.
No one's saying those are it is.
It is allegedly those virus caused the pandemic.
What we're alleging is the gain of function
research was going on in that lab and NIH
funded it.
That is not right away from it.
It meets your definition and you are obfuscating
the truth.
I'm not obfuscating the truth all the time
is expired.
But I will allow the witness to let me just
finish here.
I want everyone to understand that if you
look at those viruses and that's judged by
qualified virologists and evolutionary biologists,
those viruses are molecularly impossible.
No one's zones are no Schopenhauer's who caused
the pandemic.
You're saying they are gain of function viruses
because there are no viruses that became more
transmissible in human and you funded it and
you admit the truth and you imply
Speaker 3: all your time has expired.
And I will allow witnesses who come before
this committee to respond.
Speaker 2: And you are implying that what
we did was responsible for the deaths of individual.
I totally resent that would have happened
if anybody was lying here.
Senator, it is you.
Speaker 1: So this is just never ending.
Never ending.
And the you know, the the world is looking
at how a doctor who has devoted his life to
trying to prevent pandemics and communicable
disease, infectious disease, has become, you
know, if not enemy number one, sort of co
enemy number.
Or one to a particular political contingent
in the United States.
It's humiliating and it's embarrassing and
do not expect this to stop any time soon.
If you want to see more about the gain of
function distinctions, check out our previous
clip about this.
Just go to our YouTube channel, search for
Anthony Fauci, Rand Paul, and you will find
at least one, maybe even a couple of clips
about it.